white pawn cannot promote right now
because it is pinned by the black queen
against the white king
so why not step that king forward um why
not just prepare
to make that second queen um but okay
maybe it was more
effective on the last move right now you
feel that the white king and white queen
aren't
properly coordinated um so it's a bit
strange of magnus to
play that move i actually praised bring
the queen the whole way down without
having an idea in mind but
he loves his centralization he loves
putting his queen in the center of the
board stopping black's pawn from
advancing as well
it would just be taken so magnus playing
for domination rather than playing for
checkmate
carl shaking his head is three seconds
two seconds one second
one second he had left sorry kaia yeah i
interrupted that
no absolutely oh and there he resigns
it's over hikaru nakamura loses the
third game in the first match in the
final
magnus carlsen winning and saying
something and we definitely see
a smile on the world champion's face
getting the first win
in the final